in European Union we succeed with so
many things and it's 2023 and we still
not succeeded with the thing which
should be obvious and natural gender
equality we were pushing hardly that the
next EU Health strategy we recognize
sexual and reproductive Health rights
that this standard will be a common
standard from the perspective of Health
rights for all the EU citizens
[Music]
foreign
Mr bedroom thanks for being with us it's
already even in ambrosis we're just
arriving from the airport and you've
been in Poland your home country well
Poland is a country that has been in the
spotlight in the last few years for the
deterioration of the women's rights
there and this Parliament has been very
vocal about it it has criticized the de
facto Bane on abortion he has asked the
European Union to do something to change
the situation but uh how far can the
European Union go in that in that sense
thank you for having me and of course we
see the deterioration of women's rights
in Poland Polish women in today's Poland
they have less rise than when Poland was
entering European Union in 2004 so you
see there's something going wrong and
this backlash is not seen only in Poland
but in other member states what European
Union should do is to create finally a
union of equal rights for everyone and
it shouldn't be a dream since we created
a union of standardization of
roaming system of the territors
why should we not create a system of
standard rights for women rights and
this is not the case in 2023 in European
Union which should lead
by example but when we talk about
Reproductive Rights and abortion that
comes into National Competency right so
some critics says there would have been
Madeleine International Affairs to to
try to change something in there what do
you respond to that
women's rights are human rights so from
this perspective should women have a
choice to decide about her brother her
life it's her body her life and it
should be her choice
and it's not the case in many member
states and when we see the situation
where in today's Poland because of the
Judgment of so-called constitutional
tribunal which says the factor that
women cannot execute legal and safe
abortion and because of that six
citizens dies there's something wrong
and we need to improve it when we see
that among already 7 million girls and
women who passed the Border EU border
with Ukraine in the Ukrainian refugees
there are girls raped by Russian
soldiers and they coming to Poland and
they're finding out that in Poland they
cannot terminate these rape there's
something wrong with European Union that
we are not giving this right and which
tools does the European Union have to
pressure National governments to change
that
we have Charter a fundamental rights we
have treaties which says that everyone
is equal that we should have same
standards concerning human rights as a
committee dealing with women's rights
and gender equality we were pushing
hardly that the next EU Health strategy
we recognize sexual and reproductive
Health rights that this standard will be
a common standard from the perspective
of Health rights for all the EU citizens
another important issue that you're
dealing with this year is violence
against women the European commission
has spoke on the table proposal to
create a common rules for All European
countries to deal with it why is it
important to have common rules on that
we are tackling so many crimes and
violence against women is not recognized
by European Union as a Euro crime and I
uh it should be a standard there are two
important tools which we can use the
first one is mentioned by you the
pressure directive combating violence
against women and domestic violence we
started to work on that but the second
important file which helps us put the
standards on combating violence against
girls and women is of course Istanbul
convention just to explain quickly to
people who are watching us that the
Istanbul convention is the main
pan-european instrument to fight
violence against girls and women which
should be ratified by all member states
is not the case and should be ratified
by European Union to make a one standard
for for all for for example concerning
data collection I know that Parliament
had been asking for the European Union
to be a party in the Convention as well
the council that has just the
proposed to the Parliament that we will
give the green light to a ratification
of the Istanbul convention is a very
much awaited sign especially in the
context of war in Ukraine where we have
millions of girls and women fleeing from
Ukraine seeking protection and finding
out that there is no one standard within
the European Union concerning protection
of girls and women against violence in
practice what would change by the
European Union as a whole body ratifying
this convention we just change the fact
that six European countries haven't
ratified the convention yet it will
bring the standardization concerning
protection
prevention I mentioned the data
collection but it will also have impact
on education of girls and women boys and
men it will bring standardization in
help for the victims of the of why
islands all the tools which will bring
the one approach of European Union the
common approach towards fighting against
the violence against Garrison women it
will be complementary to uh to the
proposed directive by European
commission cyber violence against guys
and women also will be addressed by this
directive proposal by European
commission Istanbul convention is not
mentioning because it's an older
document and this phenomenon is
developing in Internet the we as
European Parliament we will make sure
that both of these documents will work
together and be complementary
when it comes to gender equality in the
workplace there has been some positive
developments in the European Union in
terms of legislation this Parliament has
just recently approved new rules that
that introduce quotas for women in top
jobs of big companies why was it
necessary why is it necessary narrative
in 2023 to introduce quotas for women I
know it's surprising to me as well why
it's necessary but it's really needed
this kind of tools are helping women to
achieve what for many men and I say it
as as a male politician we are receiving
as that just because we are men in
European Union a little bit more than
eight percent of CEO CEOs of the
companies are women are female eight
percent and women are more than half of
this Society there is a glass ceiling
which stops women of achieving these
high positions in companies women are
more educated 61 percent of University
graduates in European Union are women so
what happens that they're not getting
these high profile jobs is of course
this patriarchal system and these
directive women on boards is trying to
handle we did
giving opportunity for women to be
represented in a publicly listed
companies and I can tell you that I I
used to be a mayor and when I became a
mayor I started to manage Municipal
companies and in this Municipal
companies there were only men to my
surprise I asked these men why they are
not women and they said women are not
interested in an environment cases in
water supply in cleaning the streets and
so on and so true which is not true of
course and then I introduced quotas and
suddenly
it appeared that there are many women
who want to be in these well-paid jobs
and to to take responsibility for water
supply for environment issue in the city
and so on and so on so just give women a
chance they are very well prepared to
take over another new rules that this
Parliament is getting ready to to vote
or to give the final green light soon
it's the one that we call the paid
transparency which you will require big
companies to disclose the salaries that
they pay to men and women I understand
that this is intended to to reduce the
pay Gap the gender pay Gap can you
explain to us how this will be possible
how this legislation will be able to do
this render pay Gap is a reality
our mothers our
grandmothers our sisters or female
co-workers they're even less their
pensions are smaller than the male
pensions and this is a reality the
gender pay Gap in European Union is 13
some member states is more in some
members it's less but it's a it's a
reality and we need to to approach this
issue so for us the goal was clear the
more transparency we have in this field
the more visible inequalities are and
it's easier to to approach that I I
think it's a it's a fair treatment of of
the workers that they should know that
while you have the same level of
knowledge and your effort is the same
and your engagement in the work is the
same you should be paid equally and this
is not the case to conclude like to ask
you a rather provocative question you
are a man you're chairing a committee
dedicated to women's rights isn't that a
paradox I bet you heard this question
many times already yes I heard it a lot
and I must say it's an a proud to be
sharing women's rights and gender
equality committee because I believe
that gender equality is for men and
women it's not only for women we as men
we should be in solidarity with girls
and women and we should be supporting
girls and women there is a special place
for men not supporting women in hell do
we need more education for men on gender
equality of course and it should start
from boys not only men it should start
from the early School the understanding
inequalities and I think we would be all
more sensitive if this was a standard
thing in European Union we succeed with
so many uh things and it's 2023 and we
see will not succeeded with the thing
which should be obvious and natural
gender equality and we still treat women
like they don't have equal rights all
the statistics show that we need still
60 years to achieve gender equality in
European Union
it's a lot we would think it's a
paradise but for many girls and women
it's still a hell and it shouldn't be
thank you very much and from the
European Parliament I'm Martha DeSoto
and this is Robert beardon the chair of
the parliament's committee on gender
equality and women's rights thank you
very much it was my honor thank you